Hello everyone,
my name is Lauren
Rudin and I am an
academic medicine
scholar on the
teaching track.
And today we're
going to review
diagnosis of immediate
hypersensitivity.
I want to thank Dr.
Rio for allowing me
to present this topic
to you all and for
her guidance while
preparing this lecture.
Here are the learning
objectives for
this lecture. I will
not read them to
you, but I did
mark some slides of
this lecture to inform
you which learning
objective I will
be speaking about
and when we will
be switching gears.
I highly encourage
you to use these
objectives as a
guide while studying
this and all
your lectures
during your
preclinical years.
So let's get
started with a case.
A four-year-old
boy named Jack has
been brought into
the emergency
department with
swelling of the face,
generalized itchiness,
and drowsiness.
These symptoms
developed a few
minutes after eating
a chocolate bar.
His mother explains
that he has had
minor reactions
to pistachios in
the past, including
lip swelling.
The boy also has
eczema, and his mother
thinks that in
the past, this has
flared when he has
eaten hazelnuts.
She has concluded
that he might be
allergic to tree
nuts and has tried to
eliminate them
from the household.
The patient has never had
any symptoms from milk.
Jack asks if you're
going to take
away the itch and
if he can have
more chocolate
when he gets home.
So what's your
top differential
diagnosis for
this patient?
I bet you're thinking,
Lauren, I know
this is an immediate
hypersensitivity
because that's the
title of this lecture.
Now, the real
questions I have for
you are, why did
this boy have an
immediate
hypersensitivity reaction?
What other signs
and symptoms would
such a patient
present with? What
other medical
conditions may this
patient be predisposed
to developing?
How do we treat this
patient and why?
By the end of
this lecture, you
should be able
to confidently
answer each of
these questions.
So what is
hypersensitivity?
Hypersensitivity
is an excessive or
inappropriate immune
response to benign
foreign antigens
that causes damage.
The immune response,
not the antigen,
is the harmful
part to the body.
This definition is quite
oversimplified,
so we are going to
go into it a bit
more in depth.
Hypersensitivity
reactions are reliant on
the adaptive immune
system, and previous
exposure to the antigen
is required to prime the
adaptive immune
response to produce the
respective antibody.
That is, hypersensitivity
reactions do not take
place when an individual
is first exposed to
an allergen, which
is an extremely common
misconception and an
important point to get
across to patients.
Hypersensitivity
occurs in response
to two general
types of antigens,
foreign antigens
like microbes and
environmental agents,
and self-antigens.
Responses to self
-antigens are a
result from failure
of self-tolerance.
Tolerance is an
important facet
because it keeps our
immune system from
attacking itself,
but it doesn't
function perfectly
in all individuals.
This is what we
call autoimmunity.
The system of hypersensitivity
classification
that we use in
the medical field
was first described
by Gell and Coombs and
is based on the
principal immunologic
mechanism responsible
for tissue injury.
Each type of
reaction is antigen
-specific and produces a
characteristic
clinical disease.
We are going to review
each of the four
types of hypersensitivity
reactions, and
this slide demonstrates
a helpful memory
aid to keep the
numbers and mechanisms
straight in your head
type 1 is known as
immediate hypersensitivity
type 2 is known
as antibody mediated
type 3 is known
as immune complex
mediated and type 4 is
known as delayed type
hypersensitivity we
will review this
slide again once we
discuss each type to
solidify the concepts
Type 1 hypersensitivity,
also called
immediate hypersensitivity,
is an IgE antibody
and mass cell
mediated reaction to
certain antigens that
causes rapid vascular
leakage, excessive
mucosal secretions, and
contraction of
bronchial and intestinal
smooth muscle, followed
by inflammation.
The sequence of
events and development
of immediate
hypersensitivity
has a few steps
which are illustrated
by the diagram
on the right.
It looks quite complex,
so I'm going to
break it down into a
few more simpler steps.
During sensitization,
the antigen
activates T
helper 2 cells and
follicular helper T
cells, which secrete
interleukin-4 and
interleukin-13,
which then stimulate
production of IgE and
facilitate its binding
to its receptor on
mast cells. With subsequent
antigen exposure,
immediate hypersensitivity
reaction takes
place. The antigen
crosslinks preformed IgE
on sensitized mast
cells and triggers
degranulation. This
then releases
various mediators,
a few of which I
will briefly mention.
Histamine causes
increased vascular
permeability and vasodilation,
leading to leakage
of fluid and plasma
proteins into tissues
and stimulates the
transient contraction
of bronchial and
intestinal smooth muscle.
Proteases may damage
local tissues.
Prostaglandins cause
vascular dilation.
Leukotrienes
stimulate prolonged
bronchial smooth
muscle contraction.
This is referred to
as the early, acute,
or immediate phase
of an immediate
hypersensitivity reaction.
These all mean the
same thing and are
used interchangeably.
Other mast cell
mediators are also
released but play
a different role.
Cytokines stimulate the
recruitment of
eosinophils,
neutrophils, and
T-helper 2 cells,
which are primarily
responsible for
the late or delayed
phase reaction.
This phase's
hallmarks are
inflammation and
tissue damage.
Mass cell-derived TNF and
interleukin-4
promote inflammation.
Interleukin-5 activates
eosinophils, which,
along with neutrophils,
release proteases
and cause tissue damage.
Because immediate
hypersensitivity
reactions have the
capability to cause
two symptom flares, so
to speak, from a single
antigen exposure,
we refer to it as
causing biphasic
reactions, meaning
two phases.
Type I hypersensitivities
include
atopic diseases
such as asthma,
allergic rhinitis,
allergic conjunctivitis,
and atopic dermatitis.
Type I hypersensitivities
also include allergic
diseases such as
anaphylaxis, urticaria,
and angioedema. It is
very important to note
that type 2 and type
3 hypersensitivity
reactions can also
result in an anaphylactic
reaction within 24 hours
of antigen exposure.
Type II hypersensitivity
reactions are
caused by IgG and IgM
antibodies against
cells or extracellular
matrix components
which deposit in
any tissue that
expresses the relevant
target antigen.
This results in the
hallmark cellular
destruction,
inflammation, and cellular
dysfunction seen
in these disorders.
Type 2 hypersensitivity
disorders,
primarily due to
cellular destruction,
also termed
antibody-dependent
cellular cytotoxicity,
are autoimmune
hemolytic anemia,
immune thrombocytopenia,
transfusion
reactions, and
hemolytic disease
of the newborn.
Examples of disorders
due to inflammation
are Good-Pasture
syndrome, which is
a renal disease you
will learn about
in your second year
of medical school,
rheumatic fever,
and hyperacute
transplant rejection.
Finally,
cellular dysfunction
caused by type 2
hypersensitivity results
in myasthenia gravis,
Graves disease, and
pentagus vulgaris.
So, I just threw a
ton of disease names
at you, which are also
listed on the next
slide. But how do
they actually occur?
Let's check it out.
Bound IgG interacts
with COMPLIMA and
with the FC receptor
of macrophages.
Starting with panel A of
the diagram on the right,
type 2 hypersensitivity
can occur when
IgG antibodies cross
-link with antigens.
Then they bond to
neutrophils and
macrophage FC
receptors and activate
them, which results
in inflammation. Both
IgG and IgM, when
bound to antigens,
activate the classical
pathway of the
complement system and
produce inflammation.
When leukocytes are
activated at the
site of antibody
deposition, they
release reactive
oxygen species and
lysosomal enzymes
that damage tissues.
Panel B illustrates
opsonization and
phagocytosis, two very
high-yield concepts
when understanding
mechanisms of disease.
When antibodies bind
to antigens on cells,
the cells are opsonized,
or tagged, to make
them more easily
recognized so they can be
ingested and destroyed
by host phagocytes.
When an erythrocyte or
platelet is opsonized,
we can see autoimmune
hemolytic anemia,
immune thrombocytopenia,
transfusion
reactions, and
hemolytic disease
of the newborn.
Panel C illustrates the
abnormal cellular
responses.
Antibodies can directly
activate receptors
and mimic their
physiologic ligands,
such is with Graves'
disease, a form
of antibody-mediated
hyperthyroidism.
Antibodies can also
block receptors, such
as in myasthenia
gravis, when these
autoantibodies block
nicotinic acetylcholine
receptors and prevent
muscle cells from receiving
signals from motor
neurons to contract,
resulting and muscle
weakness and fatigue.
Type 3 hypersensitivity
involves IgG,
IgM, and sometimes
IgA antibodies
forming immune
complexes with antigen.
These complexes are
actually normal.
Type 3 hypersensitivity
reactions
are prevented
by activation of
the classical
complement pathway,
especially C3, which
inserts itself and
breaks up the lattice
of the immune complex.
Red blood cells
also transfer these
immune complexes
from tissues in
blood using complement
receptor 1, the
receptor for C3,
to phagocytes of
the liver and spleen
for breakdown.
However, problems
arise when immune
complexes are formed
in excessive amounts,
are not efficiently
removed by
phagocytes and become
deposited in tissues.
Immune complexes
usually deposit in
blood vessels and
present as vasculitis.
Once deposited in
vessel walls, the FC
regions of antibodies
activate complement
and bind neutrophils
to induce release
of proteases and
reactive oxygen species.
This inflammatory
response within the vessel
wall may cause
local hemorrhage or
thrombosis leading to
ischemic tissue injury.
So, to reiterate,
three things
stick together to
cause a type 3
hypersensitivity.
Antibody, antigen,
and complement.
Type 3 hypersensitivity
reactions can be
local, called an ARTHIS
reaction, or disseminated,
called serum
sickness. The first
immune complex disease
studied was serum sickness
and was observed
when human subjects
received antitoxin
-containing serum from
immunized animals for
treatment of infection.
Some of these
subjects developed a
systemic inflammatory
disease with fever,
rash, and arthritis
caused by antibodies
made against injected
animal proteins,
which then formed
complexes with
these proteins and
deposited in tissues.
This phenomenon was
replicated experimentally
to confirm this mechanism
and can occur as
a complication of
any therapy involving
injection of foreign
proteins, such as antibodies
against microbial
toxins, snake venoms,
animal-derived T
-cells, or humanized
monoclonal antibodies
that are commonly
used nowadays to
treat disease.
Examples of serum
sickness like type 3
hypersensitivity reactions
are systemic lupus
erythematosus,
colloquially called lupus,
rheumatoid arthritis,
post-streptococcal
glomerulonephritis,
infections like
hepatitis B, and some
drugs which act as
haptons like penicillin.
In contrast, a
localized immune
complex reaction
was first studied in
animals and was
induced by subcutaneous
administration of
a protein antigen
to a previously
immunized animal.
This injection
resulted in the
formation of
immune complexes at
the site of
antigen injection
and resulted in a
local vasculitis. A
classic example of
localized type 3
hypersensitivity reaction
is hypersensitivity
pneumonitis, also
called farmer's lung.
Type 4 hypersensitivity
reactions
are unique because
they are caused
by T lymphocytes
rather than
immunoglobulins like
the other three.
These reactions
result either from
inflammation
caused by cytokines
produced by CD4, T
helper 1, and T helper
17 cells, or by
killing of host
cells by CD8 cytotoxic
T lymphocytes.
CD4 T cells secrete
cytokines that induce
local inflammation and
activate macrophages.
Different diseases
may be associated
with activation
of T helper 1 and
T helper 17 cells.
T helper 1 cells
are the source of
interferon gamma,
the principal
macrophage activating
cytokine, and T
-helper 17 cells are
responsible for
the recruitment of
leukocytes, including
neutrophils.
Other diseases are
associated with direct
cell cytotoxicity via
CD8 T-cells, which
produce cytokines
like interferon gamma.
Type 4 hypersensitivity
is also unique
in that it occurs
24 to 48 hours
after a sensitized
individual is exposed
to the antigen,
which is why this
type of hypersensitivity
is referred
to as delayed type
hypersensitivity.
This delay occurs
because it takes time for
circulating effector
T cells to migrate to
the site of antigen
challenge, respond to
the antigen, and secrete
cytokines to induce
a detectable reaction
in the individual.
The major causes of
type 4 hypersensitivity
reactions are
autoimmunity and
exaggerated or
persistent responses to
microbial or
environmental antigens.
Examples include
contact sensitivity to
chemicals, like
topical drugs, plants
like poison ivy, and
metals like nickel,
which is commonly
found in jewelry.
In these situations,
the antigen binds to
and modifies self
-proteins in the skin,
creating new
antigens that
can be recognized
by T-cells.
The mechanism of type
4 hypersensitivity
reactions is also
utilized to our advantage
to determine if people
have been previously
exposed to or respond
to an antigen. A
classic example of this
is the PPD test, which
stands for purified
protein derivative,
which is injected
intradermally and in
duration is measured 48
hours after to predict
past or present
mycobacterial infection.
An example of
an autoimmune
disease that is
caused by a type
4 hypersensitivity
reaction
is type 1 diabetes,
which is caused by
T cells responding
to pancreatic islet
cell autoantigens,
damaging islets
and eventually
preventing
insulin secretion.
Circling back to
the memory aid I
introduced at the
beginning of this lecture,
this should make
much more sense.
Now that we have
talked about each type
of hypersensitivity,
we are going
to dive deeper into
a specific type of
type 1 hypersensitivity,
anaphylaxis.
Anaphylaxis is
defined as a serious
allergic
hypersensitivity reaction
that can progress
rapidly and may cause
death. It may
involve the skin and
mucosa, including
lips and tongue,
respiratory,
cardiovascular,
and or gastrointestinal
systems.
Life-threatening
anaphylaxis is
characterized by
respiratory and or
cardiovascular
involvement and may occur
without skin and
mucosa involvement.
Anaphylaxis is likely
when any of the
following three
criteria are fulfilled.
No known allergen
exposure with sudden onset
of an illness,
characterized as minutes
to several hours,
with skin or mucosal
involvement and either
respiratory or circulatory
involvement. a likely
or known allergen
exposure with sudden
onset of symptoms from
two or more systems,
or a known allergen
exposure with sudden onset
of either respiratory
involvement after
exposure to a non-inhaled
allergen or cardiovascular
involvement.
Anaphylaxis epidemiology
shows a lifetime
prevalence of 0
.3 to 5.1 percent.
However,
worrying data indicate
that recurrence
of reactions occurs
in 26.5 up to 54
percent of anaphylaxis
patients during
a follow-up time
of 1.5 to 25 years.
Therefore, it is
super important that
all health care
providers can confidently
identify and
manage anaphylaxis.
Signs and symptoms
of anaphylaxis vary
on an individual
basis, and common
patient presentations
vary by patient age.
This is not a
comprehensive list of
potential signs by
system, but there are more
common presentations
than others. It is
very important to
note that not all
anaphylactic reactions
have skin or mucosal
involvement, although
it is very common.
Medications, foods,
and venomous insects
are the most common
causes of anaphylaxis.
Antibiotics are the
most common cause
of drug-induced
anaphylaxis. Some
causes of
anaphylaxis are more
situational, such
as allergy testing
and allergen-specific
immunotherapy.
Again, this is not
a comprehensive list
of etiologies, just
more common ones. The
primary mediators
released by mast cells
during anaphylaxis
include histamine,
prostaglandin D2,
leukotriene D4,
fleetly
activating factor,
and preformed proteases.
The major
pathophysiologic events
caused by these
mediators include
smooth muscle
spasm of bronchi,
coronary arteries,
and the GI
tract, as well as
increased vascular
permeability,
vasodilation,
stimulation of
sensory nerve endings
with reflex activation
of vagal effector
pathways, and
myocardial depression.
These effects
result in your
classic symptoms
of flushing,
urticaria,
angioedema,
wheezing,
decreased blood
pressure or hypotension,
nausea, vomiting,
diarrhea,
uterine contractions,
and myocardial ischemia.
Cutaneous signs
and symptoms, such
as angioedema and
urticaria, occur
in 80-90% of
anaphylaxis cases.
Angioedema is defined
as a localized
subcutaneous or
submucosal swelling,
which results
from extravasation
of fluid into
interstitial tissues.
Angioedema
typically affects
areas with
loose connective
tissue, such as
the face, lips,
mouth,
throat,
larynx, uvula,
extremities, and genitalia.
Angioedema can
be mast cell
mediated, which is
what happens when
it is a symptom
of anaphylaxis.
However,
angioedema can
also be bradykinin
-mediated, with a
common trigger being
angiotensin-converting
enzyme, or ACE,
inhibitors, which
are a very common
drug used in management
of hypertension
and other cardiovascular
pathology.
Urticaria is the
medical term for hives.
A typical urticarial
lesion is an
intensely pruritic
erythematous plaque.
Any area of the body
can be affected.
There are a
countless number of
causes of urticaria,
ranging from
anaphylaxis to
pressure to infection.
It is important to
note that angioedema
and urticaria may
occur in isolation or
together in the
setting of anaphylaxis.
Anaphylaxis
management is honestly
simpler than
identifying it.
Once you think
someone is having
an anaphylactic
reaction, the first
thing you should
do is remove
exposure to the
allergen if possible.
Then, assess the
patient's airway,
breathing, circulation,
and mentation, and
administer epinephrine.
I think everyone
is familiar with some
version of an EpiPen,
which is a transportable,
pre-measured
vehicle for intramuscular
epinephrine.
This should be
administered into the
anterolateral thigh
for the quickest and
greatest amount of
medication delivery.
There is a new
epinephrine vehicle on
the market, which
is an intranasal
version of epinephrine,
which is packaged
and handled the
same way as Narcan.
Once epinephrine is
administered, you
must call 911.
All persons who have been
administrated epinephrine
must go to the
emergency room
for evaluation.
I'm going to
say that again
because it is
extremely important.
All persons who have been
administered epinephrine
must go to the
emergency room
for evaluation.
Once the call has
been made to emergency
services, and if the
patient can tolerate it,
have them lie supine
and elevate their
lower extremities,
and continuously
monitor their status
until EMS arrives.
Now, I'm sure you
have a few questions,
like why epinephrine?
How many times
can you administer
epinephrine if
symptoms don't
improve with one dose?
Should you give a
patient anything
alongside
epinephrine, or is
epinephrine
alone sufficient?
We are now going
to go over such
details in the
following slides.
A proper dose of
epinephrine is listed here
on the slide and is
weight-based. In an
emergency setting that
is not a hospital, the
epinephrine you will
have access to will most
likely be pre-dosed
in the form of an
epinephrine auto-injector
or intranasal spray.
But why do we
use epinephrine
to treat anaphylaxis?
Epinephrine is a non
-selective, direct
sympathomimetic agent
with alpha-1, beta
-1, and beta-2
effects. At low doses,
beta-agonist
properties predominate,
whereas at high
doses, alpha
-agonist properties
predominate.
In the setting
of anaphylaxis,
epinephrine's alpha
effects are predominantly
vascular smooth
muscle contraction.
Epinephrine's beta
effects are increased
heart rate and
increased myocardial
contractility via
beta-1 receptors, and
bronchodilation via
beta-2 receptors.
So how many times can you
give a patient
epinephrine?
You can administer another
dose of epinephrine
every 5 to 15 minutes,
with most patients
responding to 1, 2,
or at most 3 doses.
However, if symptoms
do not resolve,
involved, then an
intravenous infusion
of epinephrine
may be warranted.
I have another
question for you.
Are there any
contraindications to using
epinephrine in the
case of anaphylaxis?
The answer is no.
Give all patients with
anaphylaxis epinephrine.
It's that simple.
So what other medications
should you give
in the setting of
anaphylaxis, if any?
There's always a
question of, should
I give an H1
antihistamine like
Cetirazine or
Benadryl, which is
the brand name for
diphenhydramine?
The short answer is no.
The long answer is maybe.
I know you probably
just rolled your
eyes at me, but it
really is maybe.
Antihistamines
can provide some
relief of symptoms like
urticaria and
associated paritis.
However,
they should never be
used alone to treat
anaphylaxis, because
they have no effect
on upper or lower
airway obstruction,
shock, or hypotension.
If you decide
to administer
an antihistamine,
aim for a second
-generation antihistamine
to decrease the risk
of sedative effects.
How about H2
antihistamines
like famotidine?
Some studies
suggest patients
may benefit from
symptom improvement,
but research is limited.
Another common question
is, do steroids help?
The answer is no.
Leukocorticoids do
not have an active
role in the treatment
of anaphylaxis due
to their delay in
onset of action, and
there is no rigorously
conducted published
literature that
supports their use
in this setting.
There is a theoretical
rationale for their
use in preventing
biphasic reactions,
but this is not true.
Glucocorticoids do not
prevent biphasic
reactions.
The only supported
use of glucocorticoids
in the setting
of anaphylaxis
is for residual
bronchospasm
that is not responsive
to albuterol.
Other adjuvant measures
you will more commonly
see utilized in the
hospital when it
comes to anaphylaxis
management include
albuterol to manage
bronchospasm, since it is
a beta-2 agonist, and
supplemental oxygen
if the patient is
hypoxic. In more severe
cases of hypotension,
which are refractory
to intramuscular or
intranasal epinephrine,
isotonic fluids
may be administered
alongside an epinephrine
infusion and placement
of the patient in
Trendelenburg position
in hopes of raising
blood pressure.
Some hospital
protocols may include
use of other
vasopressors or glucagon.
Glucagon is commonly
given to patients who
take beta blockers
regularly because they are
more likely to not
respond to epinephrine.
All patients with
anaphylaxis should be
observed for at least
four to six hours in
the emergency department
because a late-phase
reaction is most
likely to occur in this
time frame if it is
going to occur at all.
The risk of biphasic
reaction is increased
in patients with
moderate to severe
anaphylaxis who did not
respond initially to
epinephrine and required
more than one dose.
These are the
patients who should be
admitted for
prolonged observation.
Other potential reasons
for longer observation
periods include history
of severe asthma
or wheezing, ingestion
of the antigen,
and potential for
continued absorption, and
of course, history of
biphasic reactions.
For the remaining
patient population who
respond well to one dose
of epinephrine, they
can be discharged in
four to six hours.
When it is time
for discharge
planning for a
patient who presented
with anaphylaxis,
there are a few
key points that
must be addressed.
First, and most
importantly, these
patients must be
discharged with some
vehicle of epinephrine
for self-administration
and or a
prescription for one.
This is usually an
auto-injector, and
patients must be
counseled on how to
use it and how to
store it properly.
Patients should
also establish an
anaphylaxis action
plan if they
do not yet have
one established.
This plan should
include both
recognition and
treatment of anaphylaxis
in layperson
terminology and in
the patient's
preferred language.
Just so you know,
there is a general
anaphylaxis
emergency care plan
available in both English
and Spanish online
through the Food
Allergy Research
and Education, or
FAIR, program that
can be printed if
you ever need one.
education on allergen
avoidance and hidden
allergens like cross
-contamination beauty
products and cooking
methods as well as
substances with a known
incidence of cross
-reactivity with a
given allergen should
be delivered in the
same manner finally you
should emphasize
the importance of
outpatient follow-up with
a primary care provider
and an allergist
especially if anaphylaxis
occurred due to an
unknown allergen.
A nice summary that
can be used when
counseling patients
can be remembered
with the mnemonic
SAFE, which
describes the steps
that need to be
completed once patients
are discharged.
SAFE stands for
seek support,
allergen identification
and avoidance,
follow-up for
specialty care,
and epinephrine
for emergencies.
We are now going to
switch gears a bit
to talk about the
other general class of
immediate hypersensitivity
reactions,
atopic diseases.
Atopy refers
to the genetic
tendency to develop
atopic diseases,
such as allergic
rhinitis,
asthma,
atopic dermatitis,
angioedema,
and urticaria.
Atopy is typically
associated with
heightened immune
responses to
common allergens,
especially inhaled
allergens and
food allergens.
Atopy can
sometimes run in
families, and
you may hear this
referred to as
the atopic trait.
Atopy affects a
significant portion
of the global
population, with a
prevalence estimated
between 10 and
30 percent in
developed countries.
Atopic children
commonly develop signs
and symptoms in a
predictable sequence,
called the allergic
march or atopic march.
The most common temporal
progression of such
diagnoses is atopic
dermatitis in infancy,
food allergy
as a toddler,
then allergic rhinitis
and asthma in elementary
school, but these
can present later in
childhood. We are now
going to talk about
each of these atopic
diseases in more detail.
Before we do so, I
want to point out that
atopy and allergy
are commonly used
interchangeably, but
they are different.
Allergy is defined
as immediate
hypersensitivity mediated
by IgE, but atopy is
the genetic tendency
to develop allergy.
Atopic dermatitis,
also known as eczema,
is a chronic, pruritic,
which means itchy,
inflammatory
skin disease.
It originally presents as
erythematous
papules and vesicles
with exudation
and crusting.
It then progresses
to dry, scaly, or
excoriated papules
or skin thickenings.
Pruritus is more
pronounced at night and
is exacerbated by
irritants such as wool.
and may occur following
ingestion of
allergenic foods.
Scratching and rubbing
cause the typical
dermatological skin
eruption to flare.
There is often a strong
family history of atopy.
The distribution of
lesions varies with
age, with the
forehead, cheeks, and
extensor surfaces of
limbs commonly affected
in early childhood,
which then shifts
to flexural areas,
such as the creases
of elbows and knees
in adolescents,
and adults may
develop eczema
on their hands as well.
Eczema affects
about 15 to 30
percent of children
and 2 to 10
percent of
adults worldwide.
In patients with
highly pigmented skin,
dry skin may appear
whitish or gray,
erythema may appear
violaceous or
may not be visible
at all, and thickened
areas may appear
hyperpigmented.
Treatment of atopic
dermatitis includes
proper skin care,
environmental control,
allergen avoidance, and
often pharmaceuticals.
The most effective
preventive measure
is non-irritating
topical lubricants.
Topical steroids
are effective
for milder skin
involvement.
For moderate to severe
eczema, there are
several biologics
that are options if
topical medications
fail to resolve flares.
Frequent bathing
and use of
irritating detergents,
lotions, and
soaps are highly
discouraged.
Allergic rhinitis
is what we all
commonly refer
to as allergies,
which presents
with sneezing,
rhinorrhea,
which means runny
nose, nasal
obstruction, and may
also include
nose, inner ear,
and or palate itching,
postnasal drip,
cough, irritability,
and fatigue. cheek.
Those with
concomitant allergic
conjunctivitis also
report itching,
tearing, and or
burning of the eyes.
Allergic rhinitis
affects 10-12% of
Americans, with this
prevalence varying
across geographic
regions due to allergen
distribution, but
the most common
are dust mites and
allergenic plants.
There are several
physical exam
findings associated
with active allergic
rhinitis, which
have colloquial
names that I will
introduce you to.
We are going to
start with allergic
shiners, which
is infraorbital
edema and darkening
that occurs
due to subcutaneous
venodiletion.
The allergic salute
is a transverse nasal
crease caused by repetitive
rubbing and pushing
up of the tip of the
nose with the hand.
Allergic facies
consists of a highly
arched palate, open
mouth due to mouth
breathing, and
dental malocclusion.
On HEE-MT exam,
the nasal mucosa of
patients with active
allergic rhinitis
frequently has a
pale, bluish hue or
pallor, along with
edematous turbinates.
Clear rhinorrhea may
be visible anteriorly,
or if the nasal
passages are obstructed,
rhinorrhea may be
visible dripping
down the posterior
pharynx, which
is what we call a
post-nasal drip.
Hyperplastic lymphoid
tissue lining
the posterior pharynx
is what we call
cobblestoning due
to its resemblance
to cobblestones
on physical exam.
Tympanic membranes
may retract or serous
fluid may accumulate
behind tympanic membranes
in patients with
significant nasal mucosal
edema and eustachian
tube dysfunction.
The hallmarks of
allergic rhinitis
treatment
include allergen
avoidance and
antihistamines.
Other medications
for symptomatic
treatment may include
glucocorticoids
and decongestants.
Asthma is a more difficult
disease to define,
but the most agreed
-upon features of
asthma include airflow
obstruction or limitation
secondary to an
inflammatory process.
Histologically,
asthma is
characterized by
excessive mucus
production,
increased submucosal
inflammation,
a thickened
basement membrane,
and smooth muscle
hypertrophy.
Asthma prevalence
varies worldwide,
affecting about
260 million people.
Asthma prevalence
in the United
States differs by
demographic groups,
with a higher
prevalence among
individuals who are
biologically male,
black, younger
than 18, and those
who reside in low
-income households.
Allergic asthma
can begin at any
age and typically
presents as
frequent episodes
of wheezing,
dyspnea, chest tightness,
coughing,
fatigue,
malaise, and
increased use of
accessory muscles
of respiration.
On physical exam,
lung fields may
produce hyper-resident
sounds or diminished
stress sounds,
and a prolonged
expiratory phase.
Pulmonary function
testing will result
in an obstructive
pattern, which is
consistent with asthma's
pathophysiology of
inability to get air
out due to bronchial
constriction and
mucus production.
Treatment of allergic
asthma alongside
allergen avoidance
includes inhaled
beta agonists and
glucocorticoids.
Lastly, we are
going to discuss how
to work up a patient
with a suspected
hypersensitivity
reaction. To identify
a patient's
particular allergens,
skin patch, skin
prick, and intradermal
testing are most utilized
and are considered
standard of diagnostic
accuracy and
reliability compared
to other methods.
Skin prick or patch
testing uses highly
concentrated allergen
extracts, which are
then applied to the
skin and observed
for an allergic
response. This response
is graded by measuring
the diameter of
the wheel and erythematous
reaction within
15 minutes of
application. A mean wheel
diameter of 3
millimeters is commonly
considered the
threshold for positive
reaction, with the
wheel size providing an
estimate of the degree
of sensitization.
Intradermal
testing utilizes a
less concentrated
allergen extract
compared to skin
-prick testing.
This extract is actually
injected below the
skin and observed for
an allergic response.
Evidence of
sensitization to an
allergen is defined
as a 5-10 mm wheel.
Highly sensitized
individuals may develop
wheel diameters greater
than 15 millimeters.
Both procedures
can be done in an
outpatient setting
and are associated
with a low risk
of anaphylaxis.
However, these tests
are not appropriate
if a patient has taken
antihistamines in
the past 7 to 10
days, has a widespread
dermatologic condition,
or has a high
risk of anaphylaxis
with in vivo testing.
If in vivo testing
is unable to be
performed, a RAST test
can be used instead.
This test measures
allergen-specific
IgE antibodies in
serum to identify
sensitization to
potential allergens.
This method poses no
risk to the patient,
and results are
not influenced by
concomitant treatment
with antihistamines.
As stated earlier, this
method is preferable
to skin testing in
patients with widespread
dermatologic conditions
like dermatitis
or dermagraphism, as
well as for infants.
Other tests that
may be performed but
have little to no
clinical value in
establishing of
the diagnosis of
hypersensitivity
include a complete blood
cell count and total
serum IgE level.
Pulmonary function
testing is useful
in patients with
suspected atopy
because it allows
for establishment of
a diagnosis of
asthma along with a
thorough history
and physical exam.
So let's finally
circle back to
Jack. Why did he
have an immediate
hypersensitivity
reaction?
Well, he likely has
a tree nut allergy,
given his prior
exposures with minimal
reactions that are now
growing in magnitude.
Therefore, he has
been sensitized and is
now mounting a
hypersensitive response.
In this specific case,
it would be useful
to know which
chocolate bar exactly
he ate and to assess
its ingredients.
What other signs
and symptoms
would such a patient
present with?
Jack is exhibiting
mucosal and skin
involvement as well
as cardiovascular
involvement, but
may also experience
respiratory involvement
like wheezing
or dyspnea or severe
gastrointestinal
involvement like
repetitive vomiting.
What other medical
conditions may this
patient be predisposed
to developing?
Jack already has a
history of atopic
dermatitis, and now
with a suspected
food allergy, he
may develop allergic
rhinitis and asthma
as he grows older.
And finally, how do
we treat this patient?
Epinephrine.
Here is a summary
of what we talked
about today, as
well as a concise
table that I found
while putting this
lecture together
for you to refer to.
I also added a few
practice questions with
rationales for you
all to use while
studying, as well as
the references I used to
create this lecture
if you'd like to see
this content delivered
in a different way.
Thank you again
for allowing me to
give you all a
lecture on a super
important topic,
and if you have any
questions, please
feel free to email me.